je passe la parole à notre collègue
Isabelle Debré pour le groupe
UMP
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues monsieur le
ministre vous avez récemment annoncé aux
partenaires sociaux votre intention de
supprimer les élections prud'hommes
l'ancienne majorité avec elle-même
décidé d'engager une réflexion sur un
mode de désignation des conseillers
prud'hommes plus pertinent à la fois
moins complexe à organiser moins coûteux
et susceptible de mobiliser salarié
comme employeur ma question portera sur
le contenu et la mise en place de la
réforme que vous avez retenue alors
qu'un rapport remis au gouvernement
précédent préconisé l'élection suffrage
universelle indirecte des conseillers
prud'hommes par un collège composé de
délégués du personnel et des employeurs
vous semblez faire le choix d'une
désignation par les organisations de
salariés d'employeurs en tenant compte
de leur représentativité mesurée or
cette solution présente un risque élevé
d'inconstitutionnalités en raison de
l'impossibilité pour les candidats non
syndiqués de tu es une liste créant de
fait un monopole de présentation
syndicale par ailleurs le Conseil
supérieur de la prudomi doit rendre ses
conclusions sur la suppression des
élections prud'homales alors même que
vous allez nous demander de nous
prononcer sur cette suppression dans le
cadre du projet de loi sur la formation
professionnelle dont vous souhaitez
l'adoption en urgence avant les
élections municipales le gouvernement
préciserait ensuite le nouveau
dispositif par voie d'ordonnance nous
confirmez-vous vos annonces ainsi que la
procédure et le calendrier retenu qui
impliquerait que nous nous prononcions
sur le principe de suppression des
élections sans pouvoir étudier le
dispositif à venir je vous remercie
merci
monsieur le ministre
le président merci madame la députée de
la sénatrice excusez-moi d'être aussi
attentif aux élections prudomales et
vous les avez étudiées avec évidemment
beaucoup d'expertises compte tenu de la
manière dont vous exprimer sur elle
vous avez aussi retenu quelles étaient
les orientations actuelles nous verrons
au bout du compte ce qui sera présenté
ici je reviens pas sur ma volonté de
renforcer la légitimité et de craindre
aujourd'hui que l'affaiblissement de la
participation ne vienne
ôter de la légitimité à ces élections
prud'hommes monsieur le sénateur u les
organisations syndicales je les ai non
seulement toutes écouté
toutes consulter en détail je n'ai pas
fait cette proposition indépendamment
des opinions exprimées par une majorité
d'organisation syndicale si vous voulez
plus de détails monsieur le sénateur je
le ferai l'une d'entre elles y est
opposée
mais c'est pas la moindre il s'agit de
la CGT mais je vous je vous invite quand
même à aussi regarder quels sont les
avis des autres organisations syndicales
sur ce point alors quel est le mode de
désignation le meilleur d'autres
propositions peuvent exister vous en
avez des crites une madame la sénatrice
ça peut faire partie des débat des
éléments du débat les orientations
syndicales ne le souhaitent pas ne
souhaitent pas quelque chose qui soit à
ce double niveau elle préfère un
mécanisme de désignation qui me paraît
plus simple et qui renforce aussi la
légitimité des organisations syndicales
vous me dites il peut y avoir un débat
constitutionnel nous verrons dans le
débat aborder le sujet ça risque d'être
un petit constitutionnel ça n'est pas ce
que nous dit le Conseil d'État qui est
actuellement consulté sur ce sujet et ça
n'est pas ce qu'a dit le Conseil
constitution lui-même sur une autre
juridiction qui naguère était élu et qui
aujourd'hui ne l'est plus il y a eu une
QPC qui a été posée et où le conseil
social a très clairement répondu que ce
mode de désignation était conforme à la
Constitution donc le débat juridique
vaut d'être mené nous le mènerons le
plus important
quels sont les modalités derrière ce
sont les modalités que vous avez
décrites la désignation par les
organisations syndicales en fonction de
leur représentativité sur le territoire
concerné pourquoi faut-il une ordonnance
non pas pour vous cacher quelque chose
mais parce que la mise au point de cette
désignation sur le territoire concerné
en fonction de la représentativité des
organisations syndicales nécessite une
multitude d'articles extrêmement
techniques dont je ne pense pas qu'il
vous aurait véritablement passionné donc
le principe qui peut être contesté c'est
la désignation par les organisations
syndicales la modalité c'est en fonction
de leur représentativité sur le
territoire du
sur le ressort du tribunal concerné
voilà les grands principes qui sont les
principes dont nous aurons à débattre
ici même madame la sénatrice
merci madame la sénatrice
très rapidement notre groupe est opposé
au règlement de cette question par un
projet de loi adopté d'abord avec la
procédure d'urgence et en plus
habilitant le gouvernement a statué par
voie d'ordonnance décaississant
totalement le Parlement sur ce sujet
mais je persiste et je signe monsieur le
ministre et je tiens à le redire que
pour pour moi et pour d'autres le fait
que seuls les salariés pourraient
constituer une liste ferait quand même
que le principe constitutionnel d'égal
accès aux charges publiques ne seraient
en effet de ce fait pas respecter donc
pour moi il y a je le crains un problème
de constitutionnalité très bien la
parole est à présent à aimer